- My name's Zenna.
I'm a research scientist at Columbia,
and I run a small research
organization called Basis.
And today I'm gonna be
talking about inference
in causal probity programs
using an idea called
Non-standard Interpretation.
And hopefully some
of these terms will become
clear by the end of the talk.
So I'm gonna talk in three parts.
The first thing I'm gonna talk about
is this kind of paradigm,
which is emerging
called causal public programming.
The second thing I'm gonna talk
about is program inversion.
And then third, I'm gonna try
to tie these ideas together
with this technology called
non-standard interpretation
or non-standard semantics.
Many of the ideas that
have been discussed today,
I think about a lot.
They resonate very
heavily with my interests.
This talk will be a little
bit more kind of grounded
in the technology and the
systems that we're building.
So the first kind of starting point
is our generative models.
And so I was looking up
the term generative model,
and I found the earliest reference
to be from the 1950s and by
Chomsky and his colleagues,
where they were trying to kind
of formalize this idea of
something which generates, right,
in other words, can generate language.
And this term has stayed
with us for a while,
and it's been kind of reused
and repurposed in different
forms of AI and statistics.
So I think many people here are familiar
with probabilistic graphical models
as a kind of generative model.
And also more recently things in ai,
now sometimes called
generative ai, for example.
This image on the right hand side
is a gen Stan model, which
is generated from noise.
So when we look at the commonality
between these different representations,
one thing that becomes
clear is that we can encode
all of them as programs, right?
We can write down a program
for a context, free grammar
or a probabilistic context, free grammar.
We can write down a program
for a public graphical model.
for a gen or a generative model.
And so a recent idea,
perhaps 10, 15 years old,
is to say, well, what if instead
of having these different
specific representations
of models, we try to say
that any program, any kind
of thing that we can simulate,
can be a probabilistic model, right?
So think of all the things
that we can simulate now
in physics, in robotics, in the climate,
you know, in pandemics.
These are all things
that we know how to simulate forwards.
But what if we could use
these as probabilistic models
and use them for inference
so we could go backwards.
So retrodict us, I think a
term that came up earlier
or infer some later parameters
given some evidence.
And so this idea has been formalized
and instantiated with
a few different tools.
And here are some
of the examples like
Turing, Pyro, Gen and Stan.
And these are programming languages,
or they're kind of embedded
programming languages,
which you can use today.
And the basic idea is that you
sit down, you write a model,
you encode your uncertainty,
and you ask your questions.
And the goal of the system
is to answer those questions
in a systematic way.
And I'll explain how this works in detail,
but this is some of the
kind of pre-existing work,
which we've been extended
with some ideas of causality.
So to take an example, so
imagine you see this scene,
you can think about what happened.
So you can retrodict into the past.
You can also make some kind of prediction
of what would also happen into the future.
But you can also ask a
counterfactual question, which is,
for example, what would've happened
had this barrier not been here, right?
So I think most people would think, well,
if this barrier had not been here,
the car probably would've tumbled down
the side of the cliff.
So my interest as a cognitive scientist,
is to understand the mental mechanisms
by which this takes place.
And my interest as a
engineer is to build systems
that can automate this kind of reasoning.
And so the high level conceptual picture
behind these counteracts
is like as follows.
So on the left hand side,
we might imagine some space
of possible worlds or some
space of possible trajectories.
And in the middle image
is what we do with
probabilistic conditioning.
So we add evidence, and this
updates our belief about
the kind of the more
plausible trajectories
of how the world evolved.
And counterfactual is
an interesting construct
which combines probabilistic conditioning
with causal interventions.
So it's basically saying,
well, given what I know,
which is a middle image,
what would've happened
had we made this cut
or this change into the world?
And you know, it's kind
of a strange concept
because the counterfactual
world is kind of conditioned on
or affected by what actually
happened in the real world,
even though it doesn't really exist
in some meaningful sense.
And so, as has come up
earlier in the talk,
it's been a lot of work in
the recent decades of trying
to formalize this intuition,
of our ability to ask
these what if questions
and turn them into a kind
of a systematic mathematical framework.
And one of the key ideas
behind this is the cause and intervention.
So causal probably is
programming languages
build upon this paradigm,
which we've seen in our conference,
in our workshop so far,
kind of the Palian approach
to structural causality by
instantiating a do operator,
an intervention operator in the context
of a programming language, right?
And so what this would allow us to do
is to do causal interventions
and correspondingly
counterfactual inference,
not just in simple graphical models,
but in any program that you can write down
in any program language, right?
And so, conceptually
we have this operator,
which we call do, and the
meaning is as follows.
So if I say, Y sub X equals
x given, do you know X
is a scientist small X?
I think there's some kind of
syntax thing which is broken.
It should be an arrow,
not an exclamation mark.
What this means is that
Y sub X is the value
of Y had X been set to small X
instead of what it happened to be, right?
So lemme just show you a
very simple, simple example.
So suppose we know that X equals two,
and then I say Y equals two times X.
So now I know that Y is four,
and so this y sub X, which is
why given two x is assigned
to three has the value of six.
So it's the value of Y
you know, had X been set
to something different to
what it was actually set to, right?
So it's a very simple idea,
but this is at the foundation
of causal reasoning.
And a counterfactual combines that ability
to do causal interventions with
probabilistic conditioning.
So now I can say, you know, y give
and do X goes to X conditioned
on evidence, right?
So as we saw in my kind
of my previous diagram,
we can incorporate data
back into this model.
Okay, so that's the, there's
a very simple ingredient
and we've been building some systems
that take this idea and
instantiate it into a system
that you can use to ask
very complex questions.
And so my PhD work was on kind
of the semantics and the idea behind this.
And now we've been building more
and more robust systems that
capture a kind of a wider
and wider set of problems
that you might care about.
And the most recent
system is called ChiRho.
Very, very new, an output from basis.
And I recommend you go and check it out.
We've got lots of tutorials,
which I'll go through one of right now.
So the idea of a dynamical system
and time has come up a lot
in this conference so far.
And the way that we approach this
in kind of causal publicity
programming is to say, well,
let's take any kind of dynamical system
that you could express,
for example, an ODE model
or a PDE, and let's make a
Bayesian version of that.
And now let's do counterfactual inference
with that kind of model.
So what I'm showing you on the screen
is just a very small code snippet,
which is encoding an SIR model,
which is the kind of model we use
in kind of pandemic
modeling where you've got
S for susceptible, I for
infected, R for recovered
to denote these three
different population sizes
kind of evolving independently over time.
And so this is what it would
look like a normal SIR model,
the kind of, which, I'm sure many
of you have seen, and then
we've got some samples
of data which we're gonna condition on.
So the next step in using
a causal probably programming language
is to make it bayesian.
And what this means is
taking your parameters,
which are normally fixed
and turning them into
distributions, right?
So this SIR model has a
beta and gamma parameter,
and now instead of saying
that they're concrete numbers,
we're gonna use, I think in
this case, a beta distribution
and a gamma distribution
to express our uncertainty
about what these values could be.
And what I'm showing you here
is just a visual
illustration of this, right?
So we've got a confidence
interval showing kind
of a belief about the possible values
that would kind of be implied
over the trajectories
given these distributions
over the parameters, right?
So these very broad, kind of
a wide shaded areas are
showing that there's lots
of uncertainty about how the
system will evolve over time.
And then the next thing you do
in a causal probabilistic program language
is that you just ask
your inference question.
You say, well, given
this data, now tell me
what I should believe about
the future trajectories
of the system.
And the inference system
will automatically solve
that for you, right?
So this is, it's not zero code,
but it's a small amount of code compared
to what you'd have to do
if you wanted to kind
of encode this by hand.
And the result is the
posterior distribution
or the conditional distribution
or the distribution given the evidence
of what we should believe about
how the system would evolve
given our data, right?
And as you can see from
this very kind of broad,
high variance distribution,
we now have a much tighter distribution.
We're more informed about
how the world might evolve.
So, so far I've spoken purely
about probabilistic inference, right?
I've taken a dynamical system,
I've put some prize over the
parameters to make it Bayesian.
I've used the publicity programming system
to automate inference,
and now I've got a belief about
what's called a posterior
predictive distribution.
But now we wanna go into causality
and cause and interventions, right?
So suppose you work in government
and you wanna know the
impact of an intervention
on the public, is your
lockdown policy going to work?
And so the way that we can encode this
is to basically impose
an intervention over this
beta parameter, right?
So we can have some
function of time encoding,
like how much we're gonna force the value
of beta to vary over time.
And this changes our
dynamical system a little bit.
And for some reason, a lot of
these methods got messed up.
So you're just gonna have to imagine this
as a well-formed dynamical system.
And then we basically write
a little bit of code, right?
To encode the intervention
that we want to express, right?
And again, this is not no code,
but it's a small amount of
code, and we're including all
of the previous code that
we've already written.
So there's this notion of
compositionally that we get.
We don't have to rewrite everything
from scratch to consider
every new question
that we might want to ask.
In the same way as a
human, I don't have to,
I can ask many different
questions given my state
of knowledge about how the world works.
And so this is the
inference system turns away,
and it gives us an inference
about what would happen if we were
to instantiate this
intervention into the world.
And what we see by you can
see on the left hand side,
we have this, they're susceptible, right?
And these two bars are showing the period
in which we're applying this intervention.
You can see that it goes down,
you can see the infection,
the infected rate stays
pretty much constant,
and the recovery rate, you
know, increases, right?
So this has given us some indication
that our lockdown policy
is going to work, right?
And again, this is the causal intervention
and it's the counterfactual
because it's conditional on the evidence
that we've seen so far in the world
and we can make things
more complex, right?
And this is one of the
really nice features.
- A quick question.
- Yeah.
- [Moderator] So these three
populations are considered
to be completely distinct, right?
With no overlaps
and no movement from one to
the other over the timescale
that you have down there?
- Well, they're kind of correlated
by the dynamical system.
Yeah, so they're not independent,
they're related in that sense.
So they're all part of
the same model, yeah.
But yeah, that's the most
basic kind of intervention.
We chose some start point
and some endpoint in which we
wanna apply this intervention.
But as it's come up earlier in discussion,
there's more complex ways
we want to intervene into the world.
And an intervention really
should be sort of as a model
of how people might
interact with the world.
And so, for example, we might not believe
that if we decide to put in
place our policy at, you know,
T equals one, that the world will respond
in the way that we want.
And so one of the nice
things about a probabilistic
programming language is that
we can just say, well actually,
well, let's just set this, this start time
and this end time to be
unknown or uncertain, right?
So we have some desire
to influence the world,
but we don't quite know when and how
and to what degree our
policy is going to be adopted
by society, right?
And so this is just showing
the results of this kind
of inference, and the results
are different, as you can see.
There's more variants in the result.
And the main point here
is that to go from my simple intervention
to a more complex intervention
is a trivial change of code.
Whereas, previously somebody would write
an entire paper
about this new kind of
counterfactual inference.
And so, ChiRho as a system is very new,
but we are kind of
steadily incorporating more
and more kinds of counterfactual
and causal reasoning that you might,
that you might read in paper.
And so we've got many examples
with quite complex simulations,
assessing the causal
impact of genes of, sorry,
of different therapies on genes.
And the grand vision is to
incorporate the entire tool set
of things that people
use in causal inference
within a systematic
framework that is composable
and can be extended to new models, right?
And to new methods in a
very straightforward way.
Okay, so one of the things
that arises when you work
with simulation models is this kind
of likelihood free inference regime.
How do you condition simulation model?
You've got some complex model,
it runs for a long time.
And in some ways you
wanna constrict the output
of this model to be consistent
with some data that you have.
And so this is the problem
that many people have thought about.
If you are kind of very in the
weeds of probably inferences,
things like A, B, C,
approximate basing computation
and others, and we've been thinking about
this from a programming perspective
and from an inverse function perspective.
So what is an inverse problem?
Well, at a high level you've
got some forward function F
and some output I, so sorry, output Y
and you wanna find some input x
such that F of X is equal to Y.
That's a kind of an inverse
problem in the simplest sense.
And so we can say like,
what is programming version?
Well, it's the same thing, but instead
of just thinking about
mathematical functions,
we're gonna talk about programs
that compute those functions.
So you've got some simulator
and it's got some output that we know
and we wanna find the inputs
that are consistent with that.
So let me give you two examples
why we should care about this.
So one is in just an inference in general.
So I suppose, well not
suppose, no, the real world
is three dimensional, right?
I think we can mostly agree on that.
But what we observe as humans
is two dimensional, right?
Our eyes are basically cameras.
And so somehow as humans,
we have the ability to look into the world
and figure out the three
dimensional structure
of the world given our
two dimensional input.
And so you can think about this
as an inverse problem, right?
Because we understand the forward process,
which goes from the
three dimensional world
to a two dimensional image
that's sometimes called
rendering or computer graphics.
That's what powers our video games
and the animations we see.
But what we want is the inverse of that.
We wanna go from the 2D to the 3D.
So what if we could invert
this rendering algorithm?
It would then be an
inference algorithm, right?
Or in robotics and control, right?
We have a forward kinematic
function, which tells us,
if I know the kind of the
joint angles of a robot,
it will tell me where the hand is.
But what I want is the
inverse of that to say, well,
where should I put my
joint angles in order
to get my hand to this position?
And so the first challenge that you'll see
is basically the non
invert of these functions,
almost any interesting function
that you want to kind of use
for inference is not invertible.
And so in the case of
this kind of graphics
and rendering, like why is that?
Well, one simple reason
is occlusion, right?
If I had some green ball behind my back,
you would see the same thing.
And so there's ambiguity about
what is the true reality conditional
on the evidence that you've observed.
Or even in the case of
something as simple as addition,
if I tell you that X
plus Y is equal to five,
you don't know what x and Y
are, you could be one in three,
sorry, one in four, I can't add,
it could be zero and five, right?
There's an infinite set of combinations
which sum to five.
And so the basic approach that I took
to this problem is an idea
we call parametric inversion.
And this, it is unfortunate
here that the math has got
so messed up because it does matter.
But the basic idea is to
define a generalization
of the notion of an inverse.
And so, if the conceptual understanding
is that for any given
output of a function,
let's say addition,
there's, as we just said,
there's a set of possible inputs
that map to that same output.
And let's try to parametrically
represent that set.
So we're gonna define a new function
of which we call a parametric inverse,
which takes a value in the output
of the original function
and goes backwards.
But it uses a parameter to kind of select
between the different possible inputs
that map to the same output.
So what is the high level idea?
So the high level idea,
the high level goal
is that you write down a program
in your favorite programming language,
whether that's Python
or Julia or whatever.
Now instead of running
that program forward,
you can run it backwards, right?
So you can say, well, I know the output
and I know some parameters
and that's gonna allow me to
run this program backwards
and choose one of the inputs
that map to the same output.
So lemme just give you an example
of what a parametric inverse is.
So take addition, as
we've been using X plus,
let's say Z equals X plus Y
or F of X equals x plus Y, F
of x and Y equals x plus y.
A parametric inverse of this
function will take in a value Z
take in a parameter theta,
and it will return two
values, one for X, one for Y,
and those values will be
Z minus theta and theta.
So the point is that Z
minus theta plus theta
is equal to Z, right?
And the other point is
that as I vary theta,
I'm getting back all the
different combinations
of X and Y which map two Z, right?
So now I've got a way
to generalize inversion
for a non invertible
function that allows me
to parametrically select
the different inputs
that map to the same output.
And I can do the same
for the square function.
And if you think about this,
you could do it the same
for many of your favorite
functions that you use every day.
Okay, so I'll skip this aside
because it's too hard to read,
but that's the basic definition.
Okay, so you know, what we've seen
is that we can take simple
functions like addition
or square root or square function,
and we can define these
parametric inverses,
which generalize the notion of inversion.
But our goal is to invert
complicated simulation models.
And so the key idea behind
parametric inversion
is composition.
And that is any complicated model
or any complicated program
ultimately reduces down
to a small set of primitives
composed together.
That's how programming languages work.
That's what allows us to write programs
of millions of lines of code.
And so the basic algorithm
behind parametric inversion
is to take a composition,
and we'll just start
with the composition of
two functions, addition
and a square function, right?
And we'll take that addition
and we'll replace it with
its parametric inverse one
that we just defined.
And we'll take the square function
and we'll replace that with
its parametric inverse,
and then we'll reverse the
order of the composition.
So that procedure is a
mechanism to turn a program
into its parametric inverse, right?
- Okay, and this is just
saying that in words,
but this is in some
ways a very large claim.
Like it maybe sounds simple,
but I'm basically arguing
that you can have a mechanical procedure
to invert arbitrary
arbitrarily complex programs.
And if you can do such a thing,
it vastly expands the space
of inference methods that we can develop
and the space of problems that
we can solve in this paradigm
of simulation based inference.
So you should be skeptical,
and the reason you should be skeptical
is kind of explained by this example.
So if I have this slightly
more complex function, right,
which is just F of X and Y,
FX and Y equals x, y plus x,
and I'm using this green
function to just duplicate Y
before adding it, one of the issues
that arises is that if
I try to go backwards,
I apply the procedures
that I just described.
I've taken the multiplication,
I've inverted that,
I've taken the addition,
I've inverted that
and I've taken this
duplication and inverted that,
and I've run the whole thing backwards.
One of the issues that comes up
is there are some constraints
on the parameter spaces
that arise on the addition
and the multiplication that can lead
to inconsistencies if you
choose the wrong things.
In other words, the
parametric inverse is correct,
but you might put in some parameter values
which are invalid.
So it's a partial function.
So the procedure that I just described,
everything I've told you so far is true.
We have a mechanical
procedure, an algorithm
to invert programs,
but it could be the
case that it's undefined
as some of the parameter values.
And so, why does this occur?
And I think it actually
relates heavily to some
of the more philosophical
things that have come up today,
which is that in the four direction,
there's really just like one way to go.
And in the backwards direction,
there's many choices
that you have to make.
It's almost like every
computational operation,
you're making a choice about what to do,
and your parameter value is choosing that.
And you can choose some parts
which are just impossible
in the forward direction, right?
And if you do so, you'll get stuck
and you'll kind of be
doing the wrong thing.
And so, this gives us a kind of a paradigm
for thinking about inference.
So normally if you think about
black box based inference,
I've got some model
and I wanna find some X
such that FX equal to Y,
I could do some search over the space of X
and I could check, you
know, is this equal to Y?
And I could do some check,
and if I get close enough, I'll be happy.
That's how approximate computation works.
With parametric inversion,
you have a kind of a different problem,
which you actually start
with the output, you run it backwards,
but you might fall into
a different problem,
which is that your parameters
are not quite what you want.
And so we put a lot of
effort into trying to solve
that problem and to just say
our approach very briefly,
we use machine learning
to help us find good parts
of this parameter space.
And it turns out that actually
we can generate data sets
of inputs, outputs, and parameters,
and use machine learning models
to help us navigate this
parameter space to choose good,
to kind of find the
good parts of the space.
And also more broadly, and again, related
to some of the more philosophical issues,
it turns out that you
don't actually just have
to go forward or backwards.
You can actually navigate in
almost arbitrary direction
inside the structure of a model.
And this really kind of
changes how you think about
what a program is, right?
A program is really defining relationships
between different parts of things
that you care about and how
you kind of execute that
or kind of run that there's a lot
of flexibility in what you decide to do.
Okay, I'm gonna step back
and just quickly take
a broader view, which is that many modes
of reasoning can be
understood as different kinds
of program transformations.
But an even more basic question
is what is a program, right?
So I'm sure everybody or most
people here have programmed,
but the way that we think
about programming languages
in kind of the theoretical community
is that a program has some syntax, right?
Some kind of well structured form
of writing programs and it has
some semantics, some meaning
to those programs
and it has some implementation, a compiler
or an interpreter that
actually runs those programs.
And the way that PR people kind
of think about programs is
they write these little tables
and rule systems to
define what programs are.
And program transformations
are in my view,
this kind of hidden technology,
which is powering the entire
machine learning revolution.
So think about automatic
differentiation, right?
Which is essentially
how deep learning works.
Well, what is it?
It's a program transformation.
You're taking some program and you convert
that into a program that
computes the gradient, right?
You don't do this, some system does this,
you know, you just write
torch stock, right?
Or whatever, a high level thing.
But in the background, there's some system
which is transforming
the underlying program
to turn a function into its derivative.
So my narrower, broader view
is that a lot of the things
that we want reasoning systems to do
can be understood not just
as program transformations,
but as what you might call
semantics transformations
or non-standard interpretations.
And going back to the example
that I had at the start
with two times X and so on,
the way that this is actually formalized
is as a transformation to this semantics
of this programming language, right?
So this dual operator is
taking the normal meaning
of a program and changing it in a way such
that it makes sense to
do this kind of backwards
modification of the kind
of the parent variables.
And so, there's been this kind
of emerging paradigm of tools
like JAX, Cassette, Enzyme,
which are allowing us as kind
of inference method designers
to implement these kind
of program transformations
within the same language.
And it's opened up
automatic differentiation.
It's how parametric
inversion is implemented,
it's how cause of
interventions are implemented.
And I expect many
of the more advanced inference
methods going forward will
rely on this technology.
Okay, so to conclude, causal
probabilistic programming
a is a new paradigm that
allows you to encode programs
or models as programs
and automates inference
so that you can just ask the
questions that you care about.
And at least in the idealized world,
it automatically computes
the answers for you.
Programming version is at the heart
of simulation based inference
because somehow you need
to find inputs that map
to a given output.
The next generation of inference
methods will not be black box.
And by black box, I mean just
using the input and output,
they're gonna introspect
or inspect into the
internal structure of models
and they'll rely on program
transformations to do so.
And finally there's an emerging class
of tools which are
starting to mechanize this,
which I think everyone
should just be aware of.
There are many challenges
and many difficult things,
which I'll be happy to talk about,
but this is the end of my talk
and this is some of the
stuff that we're working on
at Basis, which is a new
organization to do just this.
So thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks Zenna, very,
very interesting talk.
I realize now that having learned Lisp
as my first computer language.
- Yeah.
- I think I'm waiting for ChiRho right?
I'm done with the same syntax.
I have no syntax and I hate
every other language, yes.
Okay, questions?
Oh, Tim, sorry, yeah.
- Yeah, so there was a point
in your talk when you said
you ought to be skeptical that
you can invert certain things
and I think I followed
most of what you did,
but I just wanna check on
something about inversion.
So there's one way of
thinking about a problem
of discovering causal structures.
If you start with directed
acyclic graphs, okay,
I have a kind of proposed
causal structure.
Maybe I have some data that I use
to put parameters on these things.
Now I've got issues about the noisiness
of the data, blah, blah, blah, okay?
But what you immediately find is as soon
as you have a bunch of nodes
and latent nodes, the
number of possible graphs,
the combinatorics kills you, right?
You gimme a graph, I know how to use that
to make a prediction, but the question is,
can I look at the data
and constrain the space of graphs
that I ought to be looking at?
That's really the inversion
that you worry about in
terms of causal search.
And you can look at this,
and you can put in the do
operators, blah, blah, blah.
But if I'm understanding correctly,
the parameter you put
in for this inversion,
that's gonna be pretty
restrictive in terms of the sort
of functions where that's gonna work.
I mean, you couldn't do something
like that to say, oh yeah,
there are lots of different graphs
that'll give the same surface statistics.
Well, I'm just gonna put in a parameter
that I can set somewhere
as it will resolve that ambiguity.
I mean in a structure like that,
this method isn't gonna
work, is that correct?
- Yeah, so yeah, I think
there's a few different things
that are worth kind of separating, right?
So one, in the first
part I spoke mostly about
counterfactual inference, which
you can think of as a subset
of causal inference,
less about the problem
of causal model discovery, right?
Like how do you, as you
said, like just take data
and construct a causal model.
But what you suggested is not impossible,
it's just very hard technically to do.
And one of the nice things
about probabilistic programming language
is that actually you could do just that.
So you could write down a
distribution over distributions.
In other words, you could write
down a probabilistic program
that generates
probabilistic models, right?
And then you can say,
well I want to condition
that first distribution such
that the probabilistic models
it generates are consistent
with my data, right?
So this is sometimes called
like a higher order probabilistic model
and it's quite a weird
mathematical structure,
but it's entirely possible
with the publicity programming system.
It just presents a tremendously difficult
inference task, right?
- And so-
- Isn't that constraint
that it has to be
consistent with the data?
- Yeah.
- [Moderator] It's almost
like a prior, right?
How is it different from the prior?
- Well your prior would set up like
yeah, your prior, so
what kind of structural
or semantic features of the model
that you think are a prior likely,
but the conditioning would
take into account data
and say, well I want, you know,
I want my prior condition on data
which gives me my posterior,
and in principle you could use something
like parametric inversion to do that,
but right now it would
be too hard of a problem
to actually do it in reality.
- Right, right. So lemme just
say, I mean, I understood
what you said, there's a big gap
between in principle and in prac.
I mean that's where the
combinatorics come in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
You can say I, in
principle I could do that,
but practical considerations,
depending on the search space
or the combinatorics could kill it
off as a practical matter, right?
- Yeah, I mean we've got another
entirely different project,
which I didn't talk about at all,
which is entirely this
like how do we search
through extremely large
structured spaces of programs
to find models
and it doesn't yet use parametric
conversion, but it's a.
- Next question.
No, not Chris,
- Thanks so much for your talk.
Okay, so this question set up, I think.
- Could you speak louder
please because we're recording?
- Yeah, I think this
question set up my confusion,
so I wanted to ask you about it.
So how does the counterfactual part play
into the first half of your talk?
Like, is it, you mentioned
that you condition
it on the evidence
and the evidence is the
what actually happened.
Is that what's going on?
Or are you using
what actually happened
as a more strict prior
on the models themselves?
As in they need to be able to recreate
what actually happened,
but then we go back
and do counterfactual reasoning.
- Right, so just to go to this explicitly.
Okay, so in this example, right,
so this is a counterfactual in the sense
that our prior model was this
what you might call a Bayesian SIR model,
which is a dynamical system
with a prior over the parameters.
And this is a combination of
probabilistic conditioning
and causal intervention, right?
The probabilistic
conditioning, essentially,
like if you read a book by Paul and others
you know, he'll say this kind
of, these two steps, right?
One, you incorporate the evidence
and then two, you do
the intervention, right?
And so this is what's happening here.
The evidence is the data, right?
The infection rates
that we saw in the world
and the intervention is this policy
that's being instantiated
in our hypothetical world, right?
If you didn't have the evidence,
you would see different plots, right?
You'd see-
- You'd see
fundamentally different shapes.
- Yeah, you'd see different shapes, right?
And so, these two parts conditioning
and intervention are what
make in a particular pattern
are what make a counterfactual.
And the program has both
of these parts in a very explicit way,
I feel like, does that
answer your question?
- [Participant] Okay, so it's a two part.
So first you're
conditioning on the evidence
and then you're implementing
the counterfactual.
But it's, I thought I was gonna be asking
what if we had changed
the policy, what kind
of evidence would we have seen?
- Yeah, so that would be, yeah,
what if you change the policy,
what kind of evidence would you have seen?
Yeah, I think to understand that fully,
I need to see the structure
of the question, but it's possible.
- [Participant] Okay, maybe I can give
one more clarification.
So suppose that you're
considering what policies
to implement, you implement a policy
and you see the evidence of what happened
and is the counterfactual reasoning not,
what if we had implemented
some other policy,
what would we have seen so
that we can reason about this
kind of situation in the future?
That's what I was imagining.
And in that case, I would
say like, one reasoning
that you could do is to say,
our model should be able
to reproduce the evidence we
did see with this first policy
because our world
followed that trajectory.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, there's a,
I'm not certain if this yeah, there's...
- A different question.
- Yeah, there is a kind of a paradigm
of like simulation based check-in, right?
You want like a good model
will like reflect the world,
you could certainly construct
this counterfactual,
for example here
and then see what actually
happened in the world, right?
And see if your
intervention actually worked
and then further conditional
that evidence, right?
I think this is perhaps
what you're getting to
and maybe the point is that
to do that would be trivial.
You could just further extend
the model and it would
automatically update
in the way that you would expect.
- [Moderator] So in the
interest of going to lunch,
let's thank Zenna
and continue the conversation over lunch.
(audience applauding)